[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hi,
I'm Dustin Kirkland
and I'm here with
Saad Ali, tech lead
at Google for storage
in Kubernetes.
And we're going to talk
a bit about, maybe,
your views on some of
the big problems left
to solve in the Kubernetes
technical arena.
SAAD ALI: Sure.
So SIG storage has been
dealing with a bunch
of different issues,
most recently
around making Kubernetes
storage more extensible.
So we authored the container
storage interface project
with the goal of
making volume plug-ins
external to Kubernetes.
The challenge so far has been--
Kubernetes, we've developed a
very powerful volume subsystem,
but in order to add
new volume plug-ins,
you have to actually check
code into the Kubernetes core
codebase.
And that's extremely painful
for us as Kubernetes developers,
because we have to maintain and
test code that we don't write,
and we don't necessarily have
all the external dependencies
to be able to test it properly.
And it's painful
for storage vendors,
because they have to align
themselves with the Kubernetes
release and they have to open
source code that they may not
be comfortable open sourcing.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So
this should accelerate
a bit of the portability of the
storage layer for Kubernetes.
SAAD ALI: Exactly, exactly.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
what about ensuring--
can it do that while still
ensuring API compatibility?
SAAD ALI: That is the goal.
So one of the reasons
we didn't want
to come up with an
interface early on
was, it's very difficult to
predict what the usage patterns
are going to look like.
And so initially, we
built everything in-tree.
We could iterate
on it very quickly.
If we broke a volume
plug-in because we
wanted to modify the API,
we could go ahead and update
those volume plug-ins.
They were all in-tree.
Now we've gotten to a point
where we understand what
the interface should look like.
And we've gotten to a
point where we can actually
go ahead and create an
interface, an API, that
is going to fulfill our needs.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So the
API is separate, of course,
from the implementation,
but the API, you feel like,
is pretty well
set at this point?
SAAD ALI: It's still evolving.
So we haven't gone to 1.0 yet.
And the reason for
that is because we
want to give
ourselves the ability
to continue to evolve it
until we're confident in it.
So with Kubernetes, we
went beta last quarter.
And next quarter, where we're
going to keep it in beta,
and then the quarter after that
we plan to move it into GA.
When we move into GA, we want
to move the interface to 1.0.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Is this a problem
that you look to make some
progress on, perhaps this week,
at the contributor
summiit, or over the course
of the conference?
SAAD ALI: Yeah, absolutely.
It'll be interesting to talk
to developers, especially
in the storage arena, who
are actually writing volume
plug-ins, and get their
feedback on the interface
as it exists today.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
this interface is--
so far in your experience, it's
been portable across clouds
and on prem as well?
SAAD ALI: Yes.
The idea with the
volume plugin is that
no matter what kind
of storage system,
whether it is a
cloud storage system,
could be GCE persistent
disks, Amazon EBS disks,
or on prem if you're running
something like NFS, iSCSI, or--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: CEF?
SAAD ALI: CEF.
You can write a volume
plug-in and it'll just work.
And as far as your end users
of Kubernetes are concerned,
it's abstracted away
from them, so they
don't have to worry about
the actual storage that's
fulfilling their
workload's storage needs.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Do you
have a perspective, perhaps,
on maybe some of the
ways that Kubernetes
is helping with storage
at scale, large scale?
SAAD ALI: Yeah, so I think one
of the challenges in the past
has been that storage requires
the end user to be intimately
aware of the type of storage
system that they're using.
And with Kubernetes, one of
the cool things it's done
is it has abstracted away
things like compute memory,
but also storage.
At least for file and
block, an end user no longer
has to worry about the
specific implementations
of their storage, where it comes
from, how it's going to scale.
They can just assume
that it exists.
And Kubernetes will make
sure that it's available
wherever their
workload is scheduled
and move around with it wherever
their workload is scheduled.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And then
what about the cross section
of the hard problems around
storage and networking?
Much of the storage
is network attached,
so you've clearly got to have
a tight correlation with--
the storage SIG
and the network SIG
have to be pretty tightly
correlated, right?
SAAD ALI: Yes.
A lot of the magic
that comes from being
able to move your workloads
around with your storage
is due to the fact that
the storage is actually
network attached.
That does come at a cost.
If your storage is
going over your network,
and you're network constrained,
it can cause issues.
Unfortunately, in
Kubernetes, we don't
do a great job of being able to
partition out your network I/O.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So
Saad, you've mentioned
SIG storage a
couple of times now,
and it sounds like
you're in a leadership
position around the SIGs
and have been around that.
Maybe tell us a little bit
about how the special interest
groups work in the CNCF,
and around Kubernetes,
and maybe some best
practices you've
learned in working with that.
SAAD ALI: Yeah, so the special
interest groups and Kubernetes
are designed to kind of break
this very, very large project
into more manageable chunks.
Trying to manage a project
the size of Kubernetes,
an open source project where
you don't have hierarchy,
you don't have folks who are
in charge of large groups,
is very difficult. And so with
the special interest groups,
what we've tried to do is
create areas of interest
where you can have
developers focused
on a specific area
of Kubernetes.
So for example, I
work with SIG storage,
and we're responsible for the
volume subsystem of Kubernetes.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
if someone wanted
to get involved in your
SIG another SIG, what's
that process look like?
SAAD ALI: So we hold
biweekly meetings,
at least in the
storage SIG side,
and all the other SIGs
also have meetings
that they hold regularly.
And the schedules are
published on the website.
And we know that folks
all over the world
can't necessarily attend.
No matter what time
you're going to pick,
there's going to
be a time zone that
isn't going to work for people.
So we encourage all SIGs to
actually record and publish
these meetings, so that if
you're in a time zone that
can't attend or for whatever
reason you can't attend,
you can catch up on what's
going on with the SIG.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Good, good.
That's great.
Yeah, so, it's a really
interesting community,
this Kubernetes community.
I'm curious if you
have any thoughts
on particular community
members that maybe you
want to give a shout out to
people that have helped you
or inspired you in
the last few months.
SAAD ALI: So I guess one of the
really awesome developers I've
been working with recently
is Vladimir Vivien.
He used to be with the
Dell EMC code team.
He's now with
VMware, still working
on Kubernetes, specifically
the container storage interface
project.
I'm super impressed with his
knowledge of the Go language,
gRPC, and just how
personable he is.
He works remotely
from Florida, but he's
always available
to answer questions
and willing to help fix bugs
and gnarly design issues.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Part of that
globally distributed community
that we're all part of.
SAAD ALI: Exactly.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Well, thanks, Saad.
SAAD ALI: Cool.
Thank you very much.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]